I have two identical rectangles here and
I want to measure how much each of the
how much space each of them take up on
the plane of my screen the screen that
you are looking at right now and I want
to do it using two different units it's
clear since there are two identical
rectangles that they take up the exact
same amount of space they will have the
same area but what we can see is that we
can measure that area using different
units so first over here let's say that
this this figure is 1 foot in width so
let's say it is 1 foot in width so that
is one foot and width and it is also 1
foot in height one foot in height so
this right over here is equal to 1
square one square foot it's clearly a
square it has the same width in the same
height and each of these dimensions are
1 foot so we could call it 1 square foot
so let's see how many square feet we can
get onto one of these rectangles and
essentially we'll be measuring its area
in terms of square feet and so we want
to cover the entire space without
overlapping and without going over the
boundary so that's 1 2 3 3 4 5 5 and 6 6
in that first row and then I have 7 8 9
10 11 and 12 so that looks like this
area which is the same as this area down
here if I were to measure it in square
feet it is equal to the area is equal to
let me write this down the area is equal
to we have let me write it down we have
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 square feet
12 square 12 square feet now I'm going
to try to measure that same area in a
different unit and I'm going to just
make up this unit I'm going to call it a
4
burgle and a fergal in one dimension so
fergal in one dimension is twice a foot
so this right that distance right over
here I'm going to call a Fergal
that's one Fergal this is something that
I made up just for the purpose of this
video most people will not recognize
what a furball is so its height is one
fergal its width is a furball and so we
could say that this is 1 square 1 square
fergal 1 square fergal so let's see how
many square fur goals this is this area
that same area that is 12 square feet so
let me copy and paste this so let me
copy and then paste so let's see if we
can get one square fergal on there we
can get another square fergal on there
and we can get a third square fergal on
there so we get 1 2 3 square fur goals
the area of this figure in fur goals
square fur goals I should say area is
equal to 3 square square fur goals 3
square fur goals so it's the same exact
area 3 square fur goals is equal to 12
square feet covering the exact same area
now what I encourage you to think about
is how many square feet make a square
for a goal